and tonight controversy continues to
swirl around the university of
pennsylvania transgender swimmer leah
thomas whose continued participation in
and dominance of women's swimming
prompted the ncaa to issue a rule change
now following a vote last week they
agreed to quote take a quote sport by
sport approach to transgender
participation now while deferring to the
national governing body of each sport in
this case the u.s swimming for an
official policy now the ncaa deferring
this policy
making only has led to more confusion
many of these governing bodies have no
official guideline at all meanwhile her
continued domination of the sport is
sparking widespread outrage now piers
morgan writing in the new york post
calling the ncaa to quote stop this
woken sanity now the father of another
penn swimmer lamenting quote in an
anonymous interview with fox news that
her teammates are realizing they'll
never have a chance at winning podium
winning the podium so long as she
continues to compete given the physical
disadvantages that they face but this
woke ideology doesn't stop with
athletics as we're now learning tonight
chicago chicago public school teachers
are now being forced to undergo training
in which they were told that sex is a
social construct not rooted in biology
now olympic gold medalist and former
california gubernatorial candidate
caitlyn jenner fox news contributor
tammy bruce join us for reaction uh
caitlin i noticed in the peers article
you were quoted as saying some really
interesting things to me
uh and we've known each other for a long
time and you said the ncaa is kicking
the can down the road in the case of
leah thomas she said you don't care
about her testosterone levels now for
the last year or two
but you care about it for the first 16
or 17 years of her life and you even
mentioned that you wouldn't play in a
woman's all woman's golf tournament
because you can still outdrive all girls
by a hundred yards and you have no
testosterone
um
i know you've taken heat for saying that
explain
well i've been pretty consistent sean
from the beginning i've said that
biological boys should not play in
women's sports it is just not fair
we have to protect women's sports from
something like this
leah thomas uh first of all i respect
her right to live her life authentically
suffering from gender dysphoria is a
horrible lifelong struggle struggle and
every story is different let me tell you
sean i know that one and i respect her
right to do that but with that comes
some responsibility and integrity in
what you're doing
and i don't know why she's doing it we
we live in this woke world right now
that's driving me crazy i feel sorry for
the girls on the pen team because they
have to be so
woke and say oh this is great we're down
deep inside they say
they're saying this is wrong
and a couple of them anonymously because
they can't come out and parents have now
come out
but they have to do it anonymously
and say this is wrong and it is wrong um
and
i'm very disappointed in the ncaa they
did kick the can down the road
and but we have to deal with this issue
we have to protect women's sports they
work so hard for equality look at title
ix for years they got there and finally
got it through
i love women's sports we have to protect
it
and by the way pierce morgan was saying
you know
i want nothing but tolerance fairness
equality for all transgender people
people wouldn't go through the lengthy
physical emotional turmoil if they
didn't genuinely feel they were trapped
in the wrong body and sexuality
i mean tammy i think you know that's a
pretty thoughtful column he'll probably
be attacked for it but he's saying
straight up that
pretty much what caitlyn's saying
yeah well a lot of us have been attacked
from both sides of the aisles for a
number of different reasons but you know
what changes it is when someone like
caitlyn jenner stands up for what's
right because that's what this is about
it has really nothing to do with
transgenderism at all this is about fair
play it's about decency it's about being
fair with your fellow competitors or
with your neighbors this is about the
nature of doing what's right in the
midst of whatever your work is and if
that's going to give you an advantage
and you you must know and i i don't know
leah i'm sure she's a wonderful woman at
the same time she knows every single
meet that it is not an even playing
field she knows that every single time
she blows out women's records
every moment and that is what we're
talking about here so there is a small
section of bullies who want no one to
speak about this but i can tell you as
uh caitlyn has refused to participate in
certain women's sports because she knows
of her physical difference and her the
ability to do better because of that
physical difference having grown as a
boy and then as a male and now we know
i've i've got several transgender
friends who also agree that this is
outrageous we also don't know of those
athletes who have refused to do this
because they don't make the news so i
just want to tell everyone watching that
this is not about the transgender
community there is this is not
universally what is wanted in fact it
harms the nature and the argument about
about who people are in general let me
tell you if someone's going to be unfair
as a transgender woman they're going to
be unfair as the man that they were
they're going to be unfair as a person
that's why this is about the individual
uh and even after 17 years with this
network i i have to say this every now
and then sean is that as a gay woman i
understand the difference of living a
different life and it is about
respecting the community and making
decisions that's best in general for the
people that you're with
well then i can ask both of you the same
question generally speaking caitlyn
how many times do you find yourself
running into bigoted people or tammy
same question we'll go with caitlyn
first
well to be honest with you
um you get that i never honestly i never
get that to my face tell my face people
are so nice
right they're wonderful by the way
they're nice to me too into my face then
i walk away and i hear it in the
background in my face
yeah
and then and then you go online and
check comments which i don't do very
often but sometimes just find it kind of
fun but first of all um i can take a lot
of heat i'm kind of used to it sean
and to be honest with you a lot of those
comments that people make with nobody
around
i don't know if they really believe that
kind of stuff they may but that's okay i
mean honestly i can take it i'm about
you know
sean i'm a patriot i love this country i
love our freedoms you know and i
and i love the trans community
but we have to do what's fair and we
have to do what's right so you know leah
thomas grew up as a biological boy a
couple of years ago was on the male swim
team
a couple of years of
you know hormones and
testosterone depressants
doesn't change a lot of things you know
hands are big cardiovascular system big
you see pictures her back is huge she
can run i mean she can swim really fast
and it's it's just
not fair
it's not for me we'll give you the last
one
just really look into this
tammy we have about 45 minutes to make
sure
yep i want to make sure that caitlyn
knows and everyone else knows the
importance of standing up for what you
believe in as the parents are because we
must to make a turn here transgenders
gay people others must stand up and must
hear honest opinions about this that
there it does no good for the community
to be bullies or to not speak the truth
about the nature of what's going on i
want to thank caitlyn for being a great
role model and for doing the right thing
and for everyone else to stand up
because it helps all of us in the
community to be honest and to be fair
there's just no doubt about it